[Music]
community in chicago is stepping up to
help a family of mariachi performers
after they faced eviction from their
home when the pandemic hit
the lucero family's performances were
canceled and they fell behind on rent
adriana diaz shows us how neighbors came
together
when the family needed help the most
[Music]
for the lucero family from chicago music
isn't just
their livelihood
it's their way of life parents juan and
susie
lead this family of seven kids we're
called celito lindo
so beautiful heaven that's right you got
it
the band is their sole source of income
and their mariachi style ranges from
folk
to funk like this rendition of cardi b
before the pandemic they performed
multiple times a week
at birthday parties
events and every monday at this
restaurant old pueblo cantina
but with kovid the music all but stopped
we started adapting our services but
paying half the bills or half the rent
doesn't work and then you get an
eviction notice
we got it right around christmas time
eighteen thousand dollars behind on rent
juan and susie read that congress had
approved a rental assistance package
but couldn't find many details so on
january 11
juan asked his facebook friends if they
knew where to apply
a few of us talked and said we can't let
them be evicted from their home there's
just no way
the government didn't step in but his
neighbor bob farster
did creating a gofundme that's raised
more than 56
thousand dollars you can't see but i'm
you know smiling
the kids are just nice and polite
and talented and susie and juan are just
always the first ones to help it's like
a miracle
it's we didn't expect that feels like a
big
warm hug from many people everyone feels
a little lighter
yeah yeah i'm still mind blown
that these people they
really don't have to do that they can
just say
something nice and it'll just lighten up
our day
we feel very much loved
and accepted as mexican-american family
with roots
in guadalajara and we come together to
share
that combination of culture which really
is what america is all about this big
melting pot
as a thank you they put on this virtual
concert
reminding us all to always check on our
neighbors
[Music]
for cbs this morning adriana diaz
chicago
so great mind blown right yes cardi b
and mariachi never thought of it
but it worked